many of you have been uh emailing me
saying david you're on rumble the
right-wing sort of clone of youtube are
you going to get on truth social trump's
right-wing clone of twitter and the
answer is i've actually tried but
i'm unable to get on
and uh many questions as to why
yet another one of these right-wing app
launches has gone horribly wrong and
indeed there are now reports that donald
trump is completely furious about the
failure of this completely farcical
social media app uh the daily beast is
reporting
that um donald trump is just going
completely bonkers um as donald trump
weighs another run for the white house
he embarked on a new business
opportunity which is truth social and
it's looking like an embarrassing dud in
recent weeks sources have heard the
former president on the phone swearing
gratuitously and asking things like what
the f is going on he's repeatedly
groused about the negative press and the
less than stellar optics of the rollout
these sources said and he's demanded to
know why more people aren't using it why
the app isn't swiftly dominating the
competition now i think there's there's
actually two parts to this there's the
technical disaster and there's the the
part where not a lot of people care
about the app
on the technical side when i tried to
sign up i don't have an iphone so i
couldn't i couldn't i just had to get on
a beta
yeah a beta no on a waiting list for the
um
android beta
and so if you don't have an iphone
you're just out but even people with
iphones have said you know they're like
number 80 000 on the waitlist and it
just doesn't go anywhere so there's like
the technical side
but also
what's the point of the app i mean what
i mean by that is
what they basically
market it as is you know all of the
stuff we can't say everywhere else
because it's disinformation and violates
terms of service you will be allowed to
say here so come here to say it but then
the problem is it's just a stupid echo
chamber and it's just the people that
spread the misinformation spreading it
to each other and then like journalists
who just want to see what's going on or
people like me who i'm like well it
sounds funny i'll try to sign up um but
uh so there's the technical problem and
the fact that not that many people are
interested in this so everything uh
everything going wrong
um if the preliminary traffic numbers
are of any indication
the former president and current wannabe
social media mogul
has a point about the uh low traffic the
daily beast reviewed analyses of visits
to truth social
and um
these are uh they describe the numbers
as anemic and that trump's truth social
is doing worse or the same as other maga
social sites like gab
getter
and
then you've got rumble rumble seems to
actually be doing a little bit better
but um it's not going particularly well
and i don't know as far as the waiting
list
how uh
even if everybody from the waiting list
got on it still doesn't seem like it
would be particularly successful so i
don't really pretend to know
what it would take to launch a real
bonafide competitor to like twitter
facebook youtube etc because i'm the
first to admit that you know there's
these network effects and so when we say
well if you don't like the rules on
youtube start your own fine sure we also
have to concede that once youtube has so
much market power it becomes more and
more difficult to really build something
successful as an alternative i
completely get that
but at the same time the the premise
here like this is where you go for your
right wing stuff
that they call it for free speech where
you can say anything but you actually
can't like try criticizing trump on some
of these platforms you actually will get
will get banned but
you need to appeal to someone
other than those people
um in order to build a successful app
because the hardcore maga people that
are so hardcore
that they'll abandon twitter and
facebook for something like this it's a
relatively small crowd and so
it was clear what this was going to be
um there's other platforms trying to
fill the niche of like the hard right
maga clown type platform and it's
unlikely that this is going to succeed
my prediction it's very quietly
never spoken about they don't shut it
down because shutting it down would be
admitting defeat they just don't really
talk about it and if asked trump says
there's great interest and it's
continuing to build that's my prediction
let me know what you expect
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
just for documentaries i've been
watching curiosity stream at home for
over a year now really no better place
to find the newest and best
documentaries curiosity stream selection
is way better than any other platform i
recently watched the documentary return
of the buffalo a fascinating animal and
fascinating things to know about
conservation of the buffalo as well
curiosity stream adds new titles every
month you're never going to run out of
great documentary content you can learn
something new
zone out on a nature documentary
whatever you're looking for they have it
if you love documentaries you are
missing out if you don't have curiosity
stream it's super affordable curiosity
stream is giving my audience 25 off
which means you can get it for 15 bucks
a year
go to curiositystream.com
pacman the link is underneath this video